Hello everyone
Thank you for watching this video
. I'm Hideaki Ichi, the director of Capcom
Dragons Dogma
.
I would like to take a look back at how Dogma was born
. Now, let's take a look at
this video
.
I reserved a book and bought it, and of
course
I
rolled the dice.
That was the very first time I came into contact with high fantasy
and rpg games
.
There
's a lot of things like "Let's move on with experience" and "Raise your experience points and move on."
Especially after one comes out, it
's a high degree of freedom, like the beginning part is one
action
Well, there's a story and growth elements rpg
I entered a department
that makes games, and I made quiz games, and I made Street
Fighter zero,
but
it's easy enough when the injustice of home video game consoles
rises and
it becomes an ability that arcades don't have.
Our department also
changed to feel like we were making
both ah-
kei and this week.
The early 2000
issue was the time when the
consumer market was making a
big shift.
There was a time when a big title was launched because the department
didn't make a big hit game.
]
Originally, the same
gong for the arcade version was created in our department, and we thought that this
high-fantasy world would be suitable for everyone with today's technology.
Well, it's the current Monster
Hunter,
isn't it? Another thing
is that I
tried to launch Turn
Tofu as a game that specializes in playing that
one person.  But I also want to make an rb that looks like
everyone is fighting together on that o-line
Of course, the action-loving kid from that house
is made by a star, so it's called an action rpg, so
it's going to be
the project I was planning.
It's not weird,
but I've always been thinking about making an action game like that party play where you can play
with your own characters and friends while lending and borrowing.
The first prototype took shape under
the warmed-up home system
.
I've been involved in the middle
of it, so I wanted to make it from scratch
, so please give me three steps.
I want to make an action RPG that I made before, but
it's a late-night family restaurant.
Even
if you make that kind of normal action thing at first, it wo
n't be different if you can climb it by using something.
dene
It's going to be a picture that looks like it's been cut, so if that's the case
, I thought there was no point in making it if I didn't replace it a little more, right?
Like Dragon's Dogman, you
can climb the target firmly, give each other sweets, and read
as you like
That's why if you make it normally, you'll be able to make
an interesting action game that you've cultivated in fighting games, such as Devil
,
so don't try
anything other
than that.
For several years in the press
, casting spells on the side of a horse shows mental strength
.
I was completely afraid
of the action pressure of the action game,
so I started
thinking that I could put it in, and I thought that it was something that everyone came empty-handed even though they could see it from the outside.  As for the
Dragon's Dogma unit,
I had an image of England, which I visited during location
scouting.
Anyway, I want to see the weeds It's a country with different weeds At first glance,
the difference between Japan and the UK is the
weeds
There are so many hilly areas with ups and downs, so it's very close
to how to make brides.  To
make it very easy to understand,
I think that terrain like that is really the best match for a unit in a game
.  But
I was thinking, this
way.
I
know that now, but I tried
my best to
make it smarter--I can do it, but it's not because I'm smart that I feel like I'm on rare.
If you can play for 100 hours or 200 hours,
your cone will become cute.
[Music]
That's the
main theme.  I'm doing it with the consciousness that it
's a fantasy that doesn't go to the edge but feels like it's in the middle.
Tenne
5 said Cyclops
was a long time ago
when people saw hatred in later years
.
When I said that it might be there, I said
that it might be the legend that was born.
People who have crossed over from the west or east with motifs I thought
that it became a guideline for momo-yaki, or
I think it was twice as big as the
first one
.
Well, Chimera, that monster is an animal.It's said that
it eats the sentences of other animals.  Look, look, look at the dude that's
overlapping with the new
monsters.
There are still things that are said to be
orthodox
You decided to go back to the basics and visualize something. Once again, thank you for the
10th anniversary of Dragon's Dogma.
Here we have an important announcement
.
[Music]
Thank you for waiting.
The
staff is
working hard to create a game that you can enjoy.
Please stay tuned
[music]
[applause]
re
tan
[music]